it's a beautiful april
afternoon here in downtown cleveland and
shane beaver is going to tow the rubber
for the indians he'll make a second
start of the year i'm sure he's happy to
be starting at home he's going to get
his first look at the kansas city team
this year shane bieber with a 1-2
god i'm looking painted the outside
corner with a fastball
and that's not an easy thing to do
paint the outside corner on this guy
drilled a deep lip long run for eddie
rosario onto the warning track and makes
the play
then attendee was around second he had
to re-tag and there are two away just
hung in the air and allowed rosario to
get over there and make a running catch
the indians pitching staff has not been
able to have a one two three inning yet
in the first inning painted a fastball
and struck him out looking
shane k's two in the first jacob junis
who appeared in a couple of games
in the opening series against texas
he last pitched on sunday and pitched a
scoreless inning and threw just 14
pitches
nice pitch
it's a nine pitch inning for junice
picking up his first strikeout
the 2-2
struck him out looking at the knees that
is a perfect pitch
and kyle is bill the rookie will go back
to the dugout well all three of shane
bieber's strikeouts have been looking
so he's made the perfect pitch and he
got marriedfield on the fastball solaire
on the fastball and here's isbell he
gets the fastball as well
good pitch
strikes out his second
and there are two away in the second
knew this was coming he hadn't seen it
yet but that's his put away pitch and
look how just on the side of the ball
like that he puts a little torque on his
wrist and spins it and it goes straight
down but i'll i'll tell you what with
modesty he adds a different dimension
wow beaver carved him up fourth
strikeout for shane
and that ends the first trip through the
lineup now back to the top of the order
and whit merrifield
oh he waved at it what a pitch by bieber
that slider gives him five strikeouts on
the afternoon he's got it working today
folks the walk to ben and tendy keeps
the inning alive for carlos santana
swing and a miss he struck him out on
three pitches
and shane beaver has fanned a half dozen
through three
andres jimenez
pulls it on the ground santana steps on
the bag and was patient with his throw
and now the royals have perez and a
rundown with junas applying the tag
so once again it's
santana
starting a double play on a hard hit
ball to first base and they're two down
in the third now they want to get him in
a rundown that's a catcher if cunes
can't outrun perez i'm through with him
yeah nice job and all those years in the
indians dug out
that's a called third strike
gamel threw the bat away hoping it was
ball four and junis has three scoreless
innings with three strikeouts sal perez
to lead off the fourth inning against
bieber
salvi hits it to center field it will
carry
it is into the trees
salvador perez gives the royals a
one-nothing lead in the fourth inning
salvi reached out 82 on the outer half
and went with it what a beautiful second
homer of the year for sally
breaking ball got him stayed right with
it seven strikeouts for bieber but the
royals get on the board first
once you add another pitch or sometimes
two new pitches it just makes everything
else that much better
that is pitch number seven
and the indians go down one two three
against genus in the fourth he might
come back another inning
fifth inning
city with a one-nothing lead
shane bieber has michael taylor to lead
it off
eight strikeout for beaver
it's gonna bring up andrew ben and tendy
single in the first walked his last time
up
came back with a fast ball and pumped it
by him
nine strikeouts for shane bieber
junis may have been extra motivated this
offseason to work on that extra pitch he
did not go five innings one time he's on
his way to doing that today and well on
his way getting the first out of the
fifth inning that's his fifth strikeout
and the second time he has gotten reyes
the one-two pitch curveball swung on a
missed struck him out great job by jacob
jonas on this wednesday afternoon the
royals with a one nothing lead now
salvador perez he's the ball game from
an offensive standpoint
up the ladder bieber strikes him out and
that's number 10.
struck him out looking
give bieber 11 strikeouts here this
afternoon and now jose ramirez 0 for 2.
he did hit the ball well as last time up
smokes this one down the line but he's
out in front of it foul had plenty of
distance
to get out of here but it's just a long
strike
[Applause]
he got a high drive deep right field is
bell's back he's out of room it's out of
here
and the indians take the lead
their first home run of the season
is a game changer
and ramirez puts the tribe in front for
the first time at home this year
shane bieber has punched out 11 royals
and hunter dozier to lead it off
swinging a miss down goes dozier a dozen
k's for shane bieber
that one got too much of the plate and
taylor to his credit turned it around
and now the royals have two on with one
out
and here comes tito that'll be the end
of the line for shane bieber for bieber
another 12 strikeout game six in the
third 103 pitches nikki lopez swings at
the first pitch that's going to be down
in right field
is bell is coming around third and the
throw is way off line the royals
do not get further advance because karen
check was backing it up but nikki lopez
ties the game on the first pitch from
karen check bottom of the eighth inning
one down go ahead run it first
runner goes ramirez rips it deep right
field is bell he won't get it the
indians are back on top
his second two run homer of the
afternoon
and jose ramirez once again has rescued
cleveland
and the indians
will take a 4-2 lead into the ninth
inning
high drive
deep left field back is rosario at the
wall makes the catch the indians win it
by a final of four to two